would you say that it's that it's fair
to state that
you're really only going to have a great
experience with woman with with women or
with a woman if you're a strong
masculine guy that knows how to lead
like one of these like top shelf sort of
dudes or can you have a good experience
with women where you partner up with a
my equal or uh or a boss girl or
whatever sass girl like do you think
it's possible to have a good experience
like you know have a good woman in your
life sort of thing
i mean you definitely
can right it's i mean i've done both so
yeah yeah you can it's how you right
approach it like obviously the more like
kind of you know frame that you're aware
of and can hold the better your end
result will be but that's not to say
that you know again because i've been
fortunate where i've met a lot of really
awesome girls when i was still like in
my blue pill phase and it could have
gone i've met a lot of girls that
weren't awesome so even then i had a at
a rudimentary level i understood the
difference between all right this girl
is actually pretty awesome that's great
to hang out with even though my ideas
and misconceptions are completely you
know off base versus the ones where i'm
just like oh no this one's it's
this is not a good experience here and
then once i started getting more and
more um
self-aware and able to start leading and
guiding these experiences suddenly i
started like
maximizing even more when i had someone
that was like a good person that i vibe
with
i think it all boils down to age as well
we talk a lot about how you know you're
a younger guy in your 20s maybe you
don't have it all together yet but
you're on the path like you have it's
your potential means a lot so
i mean just like yeah like no
women will be there for you they'll help
you out they'll support your mission but
you know
again you're you're also like you're
their lottery ticket or you're a meal
ticket potentially if they're investing
in you at that younger age your lawyer
doctor medical school whatever
versus you're 35 and you're just i'm
gonna go back to grad school and it's
like what do you do
uh so you know i think that you can get
away with it at a younger age depending
on your potential we talk about this a
lot but you're if you're getting to the
point now where you're older and your
runway is starting to run thin
uh you have a less far less
chance of doing so
uh because you're just not gonna be the
position where she trusts you to lead
it's like what even what have you been
doing for the last 17 years since you
turned 18 yeah your your time is up man
what have you been doing with your life
you know i'm not going to follow this
guy who can't even
move himself out of his mom's basement
they don't have patience for a guy with
a plan when he's 40. doesn't matter how
yeah how hot he is i mean she might
engage with him on a short-term basis
for some you know for some fwb stuff but
they don't have a lot of interest in a
guy that's 40 that's hot you know with a
plan it's like if you're 20 and hot with
a plan no problem
all good
for younger guys too i always take a lot
of them call in like on the after show
with maf and i and they ask the same
question like hey like i'm like early
20s or late teens i don't really have
much to offer and i always tell guys
that any age really is
you need to know you need to craft a
personal image once so like for example
when i was in my early 20s i was kind of
a goof but i was like a nerd and i was
like seems like the cute guy and i was
the foreigner who played baseball so i
didn't realize that was my role but i
got girls
now you know i'm in my mid 30s there's
different considerations like i have to
be on my game like in terms of like the
status game too and the money game and
you know making sure i don't age like a
glass of old milk or anything and more
like a fine whiskey or wine so you have
to know what kind of role you play into
from like a personal branding standpoint
and then also know what box like in her
compartmentalized
mental framework you fall into like i
like to use the term like a fantasy box
and i learned this concept um guys in
the one percent group like behind the
paywall we talked or i've talked about
this a lot when i was renting out a
spare room in san diego to like surfers
who were trying to like get their reps
in and get on the circuit eventually a
lot of those guys got a lot of girls
like okay i'm the young hot surfer guy
and they knew it they would tell me like
bro i'm a 21 year old who's gonna join
the pro surfer circuit in california in
san diego like of course i get laid and
then like what's your image what are you
i'm like oh okay so i started
cultivating i'm
like the classical american image
and and it works but you have to find
what works for you that's my advice like
the younger guys a lot of guys asked us
that question
i want you guys
i want to in a couple of minutes uh grab
the super chat that's up at the top here
deal with that and drop the link so you
guys can start calling in for the q a
segment off of youtube but let's take a
few more you know minutes just to wrap
up on some of the ideas go ahead uh josh
well i was gonna say you know especially
for you younger guys right it's like you
know i don't have that much to offer
it's like actually the thing that you
have to offer is the element of fun i've
been the guy that right like
i'll get girls that you know have gone
out with like celebrities or guys that
you know hundreds of millions or
whatever because hey i might not be the
richest guy i may not be the most
shredded guy i may not be the most um
you know tallest guy or whatever but i
could be like you're the tallest guy for
sure dude
i'm right at the cusp so i barely pass
but you know i could be the guy that's
the most fun right and that's how i
would be like six six yep six six yeah
yeah yeah
you're almost too tall like you hit
doorways you're like you're like one of
the few guys that i meet that i'm doing
this [ __ ] i'm like i'm six two and i'm
like yo what's up josh
it's weird when you meet another man who
makes you feel small because i'm like 5
11 200 pounds usually on the leaner side
but most guys like when i shake their
hand i'm stronger than them there's very
few guys like guys like paul where
you're like
like you feel like a little man so keep
that in mind too younger guys all guys
like like if if other guys feel small
compared to you then imagine how your
girl feels and you want to make her feel
small in the physical sense which makes
her feel secure yeah
ted
closing thoughts 50 shades you know i
got anything before we start taking some
calls um no i just i i think josh made
you know some some very good points
earlier um
about
um
the girls that that compliment you when
you when you finally get to that that
ferrari level you start seeing girls in
it
when you know you start seeing them from
what they really are and you see their
feminine qualities and you get the best
out of them and since joining the group
and in the last year i've never done so
much cutting of the dead weight in my
life
to girls and when i started doing that i
start getting you know way better
results and i start seeing things in
girls that i haven't seen before that i
really really like and i i'm like wow
this is what a feminine girl looks like
this is what a girl who's into me treats
me nice and who society hasn't
brainwashed into being that i'm the
enemy behaves like and it's it's
actually pretty darn good
yeah it's just as simple as raising your
standards right you know you want to you
know you want to have better experiences
with women make sure you're a better guy
and raise your standards so you only
deal with better women right and
yep there's lots of there's lots of
great women out there guys like don't
don't believe the
you know the hype about how oh she's
always going to cheat on you and destroy
you and she's always going to cheat with
chad it's like yeah women do that but
yeah but they also generally don't leave
a guy that they wake up every morning
and go
that dude's my best option i i have like
other guys become invisible
okay like that's exactly you know
competition when they see you as their
best option
right it's like they're out there
like a lot of dudes are out there
thinking like you know women are just
out there like
i'm gonna go for him like right now
right it's like that's not how they work
it's not that's not what the hypergamy
equation is like it's a multi-faceted
puzzle right if you leave her
unfulfilled she will seek fulfillment
elsewhere but once you give her you know
what it is that she wants like the
feminine women then really really all
they want is your masculine presence
time and attention and yeah give it to
them once they earn it and you know set
that set that standard very clearly on
like this is the way you are to behave
around me and you will get the best of
me if you give me the best of you and i
only accept the best in life so either
you're on board with that
or you're not there's no hard feelings i
don't ever get mad i don't ever raise my
voice i'm just like hey just break it
down this way it's going to be either
you're in or out let me know door's
right there and since i've taken that
attitude i only had two girls walk
through the door and they're like kind
of like your lefty you know istanism
types is what i call them on youtube to
get around the yeah yeah they're the
isms uh
and i'm just like okay but most girls
are like hell yeah i want to get the
best out of the six i want to get the
best of you because you intrigued me and
i want to give you the best of me and
then it's like a it's a positive
feedback loop and you you both go to
places you haven't been before hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you